good morning John you may not know this
but in the years since you finished
writing Paper Towns Margo Roth
Spiegelman has been busy I understand
that you thought she was fictional being
that you made her up in your head but
she got out and she's been doing stuff
so I asked the nerdfighters guys if you
see Margaret take a picture of her so we
can know all the places that Margo Roth
Spiegelman has been and of course they
complied
[Music]
her skill at adventuring has never been
surpassed and when she disappears she
leave you searching through the grass
and you'll spend the next six months
with her head up in your ass
but she'll feel like a millionaire when
you find her at last that last string
inside of her she said it it broke like
that guile of those years ago leaning on
that oak see you went out there to find
me she live or dead searching through
the Paper Towns you'll find yourself
instead
where's Marco where's Marco where did
she go that Manic Pixie dream girl is
more complex than she seems
she'll travel the whole world never
leave your dreams away
in the world Margeaux go
well she's more like a TV show than a
real live girl as she jumps of fence and
swims the ditch into SeaWorld and she's
got wobbly and windows hesitant to the
doors lacking destination on the road
forevermore
go to the Paper Towns and never come
back just a message to herself before
her disappearing act
who would blue pain in your hands roped
upon your backs you have to do that
minivan and followed in her trash
[Music]
where's Marco where's Marco where did
she go that Manic Pixie dream girl is
more complex than she seems and she'll
travel the whole world and never leave
your dreams oh where in the world did
Margot go
but if you wanna know what happens
you'll have to buy the book I'm not here
to spoil your father gets you off book
but if she comes out in paperback I can
finally see a Marco I can't understand
and love complexly
oh ye bees at Disneyland Washington DC
is real Hong Kong and skull bone
Tennessee Hollywood Kyoto 19th century
Croatian monster Switzerland and
Florence Italy
and where's Margo where's Marco from
Fargo to Key Largo that Manic Pixie
dream girl smartflex man she seems to
travel the whole world and never leave
you dreams
Margaux do
so please if you don't have it yet go
out and buy it it's awesome it's my
favorite John Green book ever and if you
want a free mp3 of that song that you
just heard please go to nerdfighters
comm for instructions dftba